you could add some length to my yeah
drink a no hit they like if you don't
want to do that yeah you don't want to
get in today you don't want to get in
the old feeble bone
I break of the bone you want to add add
you know Noah push go I don't know but
it'd be nice it's one of the most
painful procedures you can do a problem
because you can get taller too but there
you got to break your bones see I'd like
to I'd like to grow I'd like to have a
well how bad you will be there's I'm
kind of a gene thing where you can get a
little growth spurt in your in your 50s
that hate is leg lengthening surgery
worth it
click on that leg lengthen is getting
popular because it gives guys or gals a
chance again a few inches in height but
some say the pain is not worth the gain
in the US the surgery cost about $85,000
hmm nuts I didn't know you could
actually do that oh yeah
that's nuts what do you do they break
the bone and they have the thing where
they inch it supposed to be the most
painful a do they add steel to it or
something I look it up chin it can't
feel good
yeah it's with me one of those painful
things you can do together then some
people have to do it but they I mean if
you so let's see that's interesting
information yeah gives the information
wait would it cut down on my sprint time
the bone is lessened it's cut metal pins
or screws are placing out the skin and
into the bone pins are placed above and
below the cut in the bone Citra used to
close the wound a metal device is
attached to the pins in the bone it will
be used later to very slowly over months
pull the cut bone apart this great to
space between the ends of the cut bone
that will fill in with new bone months
later and every time the heels they
wreak rack and they recur and then
another to remove the pins Oh several
newer techniques have been developed
this procedure they are based on the
traditional leg lengthening surgery but
maybe more comfortable or convenient for
some people ask your surgeon about the
different techniques dude I'm going on
anavar for house drone and I'm getting a
leg lift and we gotta tighten my face up
I'm gonna look
[ __ ] Gracie are you kidding 2021
think about how good I'm gonna look I'm
finding out how many 33 this can only
give you like maybe 2 or 3 inches that's
how you need there's no way it gives you
more that's how you need Anna likes
think about it
I'd be 6 1 as opposed to 511 and [ __ ]
1/2 or whatever I am oh my god plus I
could main thing I would do it for us so
I can reach people with my round house
because I hate being this close you
would think they'd have something better
to lengthen you if it meant I could kick
you in the [ __ ] face I would bring
you and I'd say I want to be able to
kick this piece of [ __ ] as race how many
inches do I need how many will you 510
no no don't say well first let's hold on
it really knows your [ __ ] we got to
change the movie don't say that don't
say that then dude I'm 5 do we have a
tape measure so we can measure me right
now we do we do holy [ __ ] it says
generally the surgery can add two or
three inches righteous how tall do you
think I am I think you're between 510
511 alright and I'm gonna say I'm
between 511 six feet get your shoes up
Eric keep mine short legs long torso
long neck long that right correct
lunchtime a long head - got a point on
my head ahead right got a weird head so
my Heights in the wrong parts of my body
we will understand that let me see it -
which is why my roundhouse kick
you're right over 511 Wow he's not
six-foot you are right at five barely
over 511 really yeah did you get the top
of my head yes do it again yeah right
over 571 inches with those you think
yeah really yeah let's see that's
curious to me people always say when
they meet me they go I thought you were
shorter and I'm always taller than you
do his name to me
yes you're smaller thank God my dad's my
dad six four I'll tell you some happy
tallest [ __ ] my son oh my god taller
than everybody dad's a large human being
yeah Papa's big you saw him saw him this
weekend oh did you that's thick like the
great white shark ivory PO retweeted
I've seen that big shark Day fun biggest
great white in history no go to my
Twitter chin this thing is so thick this
great white shark is so [ __ ] fat
thick did they kill it I'm sure they
will they caught it you know you know
how humans do it
yeah you know humans are cute God right
here
look a big this look great white race 20
foot long found near the island of Oahu
where to go wow
it's the biggest on record oh my god
it's majestic as [ __ ] I put that shark
is thickest [ __ ] we all think that thing
is
well and and so she's swimming with that
bad boy look at this there's some white
people [ __ ] here dude you see that you
see the suit though so they don't
confuse confuse it with a seal yeah you
don't want you to look like a tiger
shark to pee but how about that oh
really cuz I'll eat a tiger shark nope I
made that up oh but also don't do that
right thick that thing is she's swimming
with it just Cathay just called a shark
within he she is she breathing she's not
breathing she's holding her breath who
is yeah she snorkeling dude there's no
oxygen tank though yes some nerve dunno
the great white shark bro it's a giant
shark that's that's nuts
you be fun guys are swimming with a
giant great white how crazy is that
look at the [ __ ] look at all that is
he's been through some [ __ ] man tell you
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue Oh what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]